turning now to the continuing debate
over how to tackle
racism in america our next guest is
calling on white americans to address
the subtle ways
in which she says they cause racial harm
every day
robin deangelo's 2018 book white
fragility
catapult it to the catapulted to the top
of the new york times best sellers list
amid the calls for social justice after
the death of george floyd
her new book is nice racism how
progressive white people
perpetuate racial harm it argues
well-meaning people can fuel racism
robin d'angelo joins us now for an
interview you're seeing first
on cbs this morning robin thanks so much
for being with us
thank you for having me good morning
first of all what exactly is
nice racism because those two words
don't go together robin
those two words nice and racism do not
go together
well if it grabs your attention that's a
good thing we need to grab
one another's attention and start having
a difficult conversation or continue
having that conversation
but the explicit uh acts of racism are
fairly
recognizable you know epithats and slurs
but there are many more subtle
manifestations
and because they're more subtle they're
more insidious
they're often perpetrated by
well-meaning people
who are not aware that they are causing
harm
and are in denial about that robin you
say in the book that you've been guilty
of this yourself that you
you've made your own missteps what are
you were you referring to
well absolutely i i'm well aware that i
have perpetrated racial harm across my
life and i'm also
well aware that not one moment of that
was intentional
or or conscious but it still caused harm
and an example i opened the book with
is back when i was in college and i'm a
non-traditional student so it was in my
30s at this point in my life
my partner at the time and i were
visiting
another city and there were some friends
of her she wanted to look up so we made
plans to meet this couple
at a restaurant i had never met them
before
and we got to the restaurant i saw that
they were both black
and at that point in my life i didn't
know any black people i was rarely ever
around black people and i was excited
i wanted to immediately establish
that i was not racist so how did i do
that
i proceeded to regale them all night
long
with stories about how racist my family
was
i shared every joke every comment
followed by can you believe they said
that thinking that what i was
demonstrating was that i i recognized
those things as racist
and i would never say those things yeah
yeah that made you better than your
family yeah yes
but i was subjecting this couple all
night long to all those comments
and i would not have brought the
conversation to race
if they had not been black so i was also
objectifying them
and i wasn't paying any attention to
their signals as they grew
more and more uncomfortable and maybe
the last point to pull from that example
is my partner while she wasn't
participating in those
comments she also wasn't interrupting
them and so she
contributed to to allowing that to
happen and that's a great example my
intentions were to show i wasn't racist
but the impact of my behavior was racism
yeah
listen robin when i read that i sort of
laughed but i was also cringing for you
because i've been in a situation with
white people and they'll pull out
pictures of
look at my brother-in-law look at my
daughter-in-law look at the things that
i've done i'm thinking
why are you showing me this or i have a
friend who's sick and it turns out she's
black and they just wanted me to know
about it so
i i'm really related to what you were
saying but what was fascinating to me is
here you were in your 30s you had had
very little contact with black people
and you said 75 of whites in this
country
have little or no contact with black
people in their lives i
i thought that was so fascinating to me
yeah that's based on a survey by the
uh public religion research uh institute
and i think it's pretty clear uh in most
white
uh people's lives most white people live
segregated lives
um and are not taught to feel any sense
of loss about that
and if we're being honest in large part
we measure the value
of space of neighborhoods of schools
by the absence of black people but
robert what do you say to people because
i want to get this point when you say
there's robin trying to make white
people feel guilty again
what is your response to that i think
that's a
willful misreading of my work i'm not
interested in guilt it serves no good
purpose i'm clear that i have
participated and perpetuated racism in
my life
i don't feel guilty about that i didn't
choose to be
conditioned in a society in which racism
is the bedrock
and the anecdote to guilt is
reparative action responsibility i
again i didn't choose my conditioning
but i am responsible for the outcome of
it and when you change your
understanding of what racism is when you
move
past this idea that it's an either or
proposition
you know either good people or bad
people a good
guilt becomes moot yeah guilt is it's
not a particularly productive emotion
either right robin deangelo thank you
very much for being with us
the book nice racism goes on sale
tomorrow